[Music]
it's that time again sony have
officially revealed the free games we
receive as ps plus essential subscribers
for the month of august 2022. all these
games will be downloadable from tuesday
the 2nd of august and i've got to say
it's a pretty good month first up is the
sublime tony hawks pro skater 1 and 2.
two skateboarding classics from over 20
years ago have been lovingly rebuilt for
a new audience while staying respectful
to what made them both iconic the goal
is to achieve a high score by chaining
tricks together for as long as possible
before wiping out in no time at all
you'll be going from skateparks to
grinding telephone wires in the street
and smashing through barriers to find
secret new areas to master the
soundtrack is a nostalgia masterpiece
with tracks from the 90s like public
enemy through to the 2000s with machine
gun kelly and if it's anything like the
original games the soundtrack will stick
in your head for days weeks sometimes
months with 21 pro skaters to choose
from and a cameo from jack black no less
and over 700 challenges to master
awarding cosmetics in-game cash and
boards there's enough content to last
you a very long time plus there's a
multiplayer mode and the ability to
create your own skatepark which can then
be uploaded and shared with the world
reviewers tell us tony hawk's pro skater
1 and 2 is an 8.5 out of 10 so you
should play it next we have yakuza like
a dragon a third-person action rpg i'm
sure you've heard about yakuza in the
past yet leica dragon is different it
uses a turn-based fighting system the
new combat allows for an unbelievable
amount of different moves to be utilized
from standard kicks and punches through
to throwing bowls of fruit at someone's
face i even saw a guy channel lightning
through a guitar once and that pretty
much sums up yakuza games they are
always kind of insane in the best
possible way and never take themselves
too seriously that said we play as
ishiban kazuga who agreed to be arrested
for a crime he didn't commit 18 years
later and he's back out again but things
have changed and we must unwind a story
of deceit betrayal and dishonor the
people ichiban meets and becomes close
to are surprisingly compelling and
you'll want to continue the story just
to see what happens to those they all
want to heal the world using their fists
yakuza like a dragon has one glaring
issue in the late game a tremendous
amount of xp farming is needed to be
able to fight a long string of end game
bosses it doesn't ruin the game but it
does make the late game a severe grind
reviewers said like a dragon is an 8 out
of 10 game which means it's really good
but you'll need around 40 hours to get
through it all good luck and finally on
ps4 is little nightmares an atmospheric
horror game which tells a detailed story
of survival that builds to an amazing
crescendo without a single word spoken a
small child named six platforms her way
through a mysterious ship playing hide
and seek with deadly foes to break out
of this hell six will need to solve
puzzles and stay away from eyes that
turn children into stone and caretakers
with arms so long it's terrifying
running from safe spot to safe spot
praying not to be caught is the
underpinning fear mechanic little
nightmares gives us the story is never
presented openly yet each room adds to
the narrative where does all that meat
come from why is that a cage over there
all these questions have answers if you
look hard enough for them little
nightmares takes around 5 hours to
complete but the harrowing things you
will learn by the end will stick with
you much longer little nightmares
reviews average out at 8.5 out of 10
which means this month every single game
is at least an 8 out of 10 on average
that's that's impressive so what do you
think to this month i'd give this month
an 8 out of 10 as well what do you say
i'm adam you're awesome thanks for
sticking around it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]